[Musique]
du pôle nord jusque dans les centres
commerciaux
le père noël continue de distribuer du
bonheur depuis plus d'un siècle
même s'il fait partie des traditions il
doit s'adapter aux nouvelles réalités
avec les réseaux sociaux pour être plus
prudent pour faire attention à nos
gestes nos paroles
à l'ère de facebook instagram twitter et
dit mouvement moi aussi ce représentant
du père noël redoublent de prudence ce
m'est pas arrivé à moi personnellement
non mais je j'ai un ami que med
positionner l'enfant et mr mais il m'a
tout donné sans une main malheureusement
ça s'est il pas fait exprès l'or mais
c'est surtout faire attention c'est des
gestes compose des fois un enfant qui a
clairement dit qu'il ait quoi que ce
soit oui je vois le tenez je veux leur
départ les pauvres un petit enfant d'un
an aux deux membres et à sion que je
dois regarder en avant moi mais avec mon
bureau avec ma main l'association des
pères noël du québec offrent d'ailleurs
des formations pour mieux outiller ses
quelque 30 membres
avec maintenant les vagues de
dénonciation était les gens sont plus il
est plus à l'est grand chose que je te
dirais que oui il est important de
transmettre des codes des codes
d'éthique qui décode
la bienséance il y à un processus
rigoureux de sélection
je pense qu'ils s'attendent à ce qu'elle
permet soit pas juste industrie des
cadeaux mais qui vient enfin vivre une
expérience à son enfant dans les centres
commerciaux les photographes agissent
comme des complices du père noël le père
noël jamet va mener sur deux - calais un
bisou ça s'est passé vraiment 6 par an
le dis on peut le faire mais sinon nous
on impose arrive cet autre représentant
du père noël adapte aussi son approche
je suis simplement d'ouvrir les mots qui
donnent même pas des enfants vers les
mobiles
je veux c'est des mecs souffler ni
contre sont les automnales des jalles
avec les hypothèques les réseaux sociaux
il faut faire plus attention mais encore
leur faire attention je pense qu'il faut
pas être plus catholique que j'en vois
deux battants j'ai pas aussi un gros
scandale
c'est ainsi à cause du hashtag mis tout
petit il a fallu sa santé ça va causer
des bonnes mais non les réseaux sociaux
ben pour moi s'il est encore loin pour
eux et que je m'occupe de garder la
magie présente chine
malgré ces nouvelles réalités les père
noël reste passionné par le rôle s'est
bien moqué soit c'est sympa de bourse à
ceux c'est très gratifiant ici charles
d'amboise radio canada québec
[Musique]